en su discurso ante la asamblea general
de la ONU el Primer Ministro israelí en
funciones Yair lapid pareció tender una
rama de olivo a los palestinos y
reavivar la solución de los dos estados
un tema que lleva mucho tiempo en el
olvido que asumió el cargo hace poco
menos de tres meses dijo que tenía a
gran parte de Israel de su lado aunque
esbozó una advertencias
Still today a pesar de todos los
obstáculos que Aún existen creo que una
gran mayoría de israelíes apoya la
versión de la solución de los dos
estados yo soy uno de ellos solo tenemos
una condición Que el futuro estado
palestino sea Pacífico
pero el discurso apenas había terminado
antes de que uno de los predecesores de
Lápiz Benjamín netanyahu lo criticará
duramente afirmó que la pizza está
devolviendo a los palestinos al primer
plano de la escena mundial y metiendo
ahí Israel en el pozo netanyahu añadió
que tal iniciativa crearía un estado
terrorista en el corazón del país los
dirigentes y israelíes se han alejado en
gran medida en los últimos años de la
idea de una solución de dos estados para
el conflicto entre israelíes Y
palestinos aunque el propio netan Yahoo
La respaldo Hace seis años de las
Naciones Unidas
sigo comprometido con una visión de paz
basada en dos estados para dos pueblos
pero si es cual sea el cambio de rumbo
de la pid la solución de los dos estados
Sigue estando muy lejos ya que la
desconfianza mutua entre israelíes Y
palestinos es más aguda que nunca y
Israel lleva mucho tiempo acusando los
palestinos de no querer la paz mientras
que los primeros por su parte señalan a
su contraparte de seguir construyendo
asentamientos en los terrenos ocupados
de cisjordania